حسنًا، لا يزال وقف إطلاق النار الهش لمدة 72 ساعة في
السودان ساريًا وسط تجدد
اندلاع أعمال عنف متفرقة، يقول مسؤول في الأمم المتحدة
تحدث إلى
القوات المنافسة للجنرال إن أيًا منهما لم
يظهر استعدادًا لبدء
محادثات سلام جادة. ويتسابق الناس للفرار من
البلاد خلال هذه الفترة.  في هذه الفترة من
انخفاض القتال، يواجه أولئك الذين بقوا يواجهون
ظروفًا تزداد سوءًا بسرعة مع
نفاد المياه والكهرباء أو
نفاد المستشفيات بالفعل في الخرطوم وما حولها،
مما يزيد من
التحذيرات من خطر بيولوجي كبير بعد أن
استولى مقاتلون من أحد الفصائل على
مختبر صحي في العاصمة.  تنضم إلي الآن
إليزابيث كوهين، كبيرة المراسلين الطبيين لشبكة CNN،
للحديث أكثر عن ذلك وعن
مخاوف صحية أخرى، ومن الجيد أن تكون
معنا إليزابيث، لذا
تقول منظمة الصحة العالمية إن شلل الأطفال والحصبة والكوليرا
يتم تخزينه في هذا المختبر، فما مدى القلق بشأن
هذا التطور،
لذا إذا كانت ليندا بالفعل  الفصيل الذي
يبدو أنه سيطر على هذا المختبر
أه يخطئ وتخرج هذه الجراثيم
أو تفعل ذلك عمدًا من
الواضح أنه ليس جيدًا ولكن أريد أن أتحدث
عن الأمراض الثلاثة التي
ذكرتها للتو الحصبة وشلل الأطفال والكوليرا
هذه ليست جديدة  هناك
في الواقع عدد لا بأس به من الحصبة
والكوليرا في العالم، لذا فإن أي شيء
قد يخرج من هذا المختبر ليس في الواقع
إضافة كبيرة، فهناك أيضًا
شلل الأطفال في العالم، وأنا لا
أقول إنه من الجيد أن يحدث شيء ما
مع هذا  معمليًا ولكن هذه ليست
نوعًا من الأمراض الجديدة أو شيئًا
غير عادي لا نعرف أن
الناس لم يتم تطعيمهم ضده، لذا فإن الجزء
من العالم الذي يتم تطعيمه يتم
تطعيمه بشكل كبير ضد شلل الأطفال والحصبة
حقًا ما يثير القلق  إن الأمر يتعلق
أكثر بالمنطقة المباشرة، وهو ما يثير القلق
بالنسبة للأشخاص الذين يعيشون في هذه
المنطقة المباشرة حيث
قد لا تكون معدلات التطعيم مرتفعة بالفعل، وهذا هو مصدر
القلق المباشر، دعونا نلقي نظرة على
ما قاله مصدر طبي في السودان لشبكة CNN، حيث إن
الخطر يكمن في  نشوب أي
مواجهة مسلحة في المختبر
لأن ذلك سيحول المختبر
إلى قنبلة جرثومية والمطلوب
تدخل دولي عاجل وسريع
لإعادة الكهرباء وتأمين
المختبر من أي مواجهة مسلحة
لأننا أمام خطر بيولوجي حقيقي
لذا للتوضيح الأمر  ليس من
الواضح تمامًا مدى الخطر الموجود ولكن من
الواضح أنه ليس جيدًا إذا كان
هذا المختبر قد تم السيطرة
عليه من قبل مجموعة تريد إلحاق الضرر